[musique]
bien, imaginez
voyons ici écrit 1824
année imaginez trois ans depuis votre mort
Napoléon
trois ans Alexandre le premier sur le trône
ce qui s'appelle bien, regarde ici
un de plus
mais c'est juste un truc de fan
et c'est ce qu'il y a un morceau de canopée sous
qui sur l'île de sainte-hélène
Napoléon est mort en tout, même un petit
ville en russe s'il y a
magasin d'antiquités vous entrez et il vient de
te regarde tout le temps
trouver ici mais à mon avis sur
aujourd'hui c'est napoléon bien sur
héros romantique et bien sûr vous pouvez
s'émerveiller et admirer
ce sont précisément les qualités d'un penseur
qualités d'un stratège qualités d'une personne
qui ne s'est pas contenté de faire du pan
qui ont été immédiatement mis en pratique
regarde ici elle est tu sais je pense
que les dirigeants de différents pays ils sont tous pareils
peur d'être appelé leader
Type napoléonien, eh bien, en fait
acte dans les signes du bonapartisme et nous voyons dans
de nombreuses
introuvable ici car ils sont tous différents
napoléon avec alexandre 1er
une fois ici à tilsit
[musique]